une fois son bras déployé ce robot
agriculteur peut faire les semis il peut
également préparer les sols et repiquer
les plans un assistant technologique qui
facilite grandement le travail des
maraîchers au nombre de trois pour une
superficie de 5000 mètres carrés il y a
des tâches où ça nous soulage bien ou on
va avoir un sacré-cœur dans le temps par
exemple on a une repiqueuse qui nous
permet de planter les plombs peut-être
10 fois plus vite que nous et donc sur
quand on est en ça toute une serre et
bah ça fait gagner un temps fou du temps
et de la productivité ouverte de plus
octobre 2022 cette femme connectée est
ainsi capable de produire 60 tonnes de
légumes par an soit la consommation
annuelle de 300 personnes notre modèle
donc le modèle bio intensif où on
produit beaucoup sur une petite surface
en associant les cultures en essayant de
faire beaucoup de rotation sur sur la
même surface sur une année une
agriculture 100% bio porte des villes
car l'objectif est aussi de recréer un
réseau de production locale raison pour
laquelle en plus de la vente directe à
la ferme un distributeur automatique a
été installé aujourd'hui on vend un
petit peu moins de la moitié de nos
légumes directement localement sur la
ferme donc 40 % pour être exact et 60 %,
on va aller vendre auprès de magasins
locaux je suis intimement convaincu
encore une fois que c'est la clé pour
remettre nos campagnes remettre de la
vie dans nos campagnes relocaliser avoir
re des gens qui habitent et refaire de
la production de nourriture qu'on mange
sur place et les clients sont au
rendez-vous d'autant plus que les prix
sont à peine plus élevés que se
pratiquait en grande surface c'est du
frais donc ça dure plus longtemps
surtout ça se conserve bien donc c'est
ce que j'apprécie et le goût
fort de ces premiers retours positifs le
gérant espère pouvoir multiplier par vin
sa zone de production sur l'année
écoulée cette forme d'un nouveau genre a
réalisé près de 120 000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires